lastly so the cameras I understand that
you purchased two red cameras which you
know you knew you had a hundred and
thirty day shoot or whatever and that
you thought it would be financially best
off
how are you passing them between cars
you're going what sixty miles an hour
basically that one we were all kind of a
little bit nervous and on that shot
specifically more nervous than anything
else because usually when we do like a
pass off like we did on the first raid
it was with a fig rig set up so that at
least from one DOP to the other there's
like a space to grab so if you got a
figure here you're passing to another
DOP he can grab here and here and it's
like a clear definably take the camera
and control it for the car chase one
what we did was we we couldn't because
of the window space was too small we
couldn't put on a fig rig and also
because of the comfort zone of like
being able to kind of maneuver the
camera the way they wanted to they
didn't want to be locked in with certain
sort of like sidearm grips so they
literally held it like a box handheld
entirely so there was just holding the
cube with the camera and then pulling it
out through the window and then panning
it and then waiting for the connector
out to come up pushing it through the
open space and then the next DP would
come in and just grab whatever part was
available to grab so it was really
nerve-wracking while we were shooting it
because you know we're on we're hanging
by the road nearby so yeah we had to be
very very careful not to drop anything
but thankfully they executed it well
thank you
you